deezer est maintenant toi
débat
blais
je suis là
ap
[Musique]
m
ouais si vous va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
booba bonsoir c'étaient les cheveux
extrêmement bien coupé non mais vraiment
un jeu non avec balla je suis fascinée
vraiment bien alors booba des rigoles
paul tu rigole pas si ça va mal 27 ans 2
album certifié disque d'or deux passages
en prison
on commence par la prison comme ça ce
sera fait donc d'abord quatre ans pour
avoir agressé deux chauffeurs de taxi et
qu'une arme à feu je suis liberté
conditionnelle au bout de 18 mois
pourquoi ce que tu as à mars alors
c'était pas bien méchants ils ont été un
peu dure un peu dur avec moi ensuite
quatre mois de préventive pour tentative
d'homicide volontaire
le procureur a réclamé trois ans mais
vous avez été relaxé parce que fussent
les mouvements ouais je regrette je
regrette de m'être fait rattraper
surtout tu dis que les gens qui sont en
prison en fait y en a très peu qui
regrette donc on sait pas faire attraper
je ne connais peu qu'ils vont prendre de
leur plein gré pour moi en disant je
regrette ce que j'ai fait voilà alors
vous êtes booba métisse franco
sénégalais né dans les hauts-de-seine
vers 10-11 ans quand vos parents
divorcent vous partez avec votre mère à
cagnes-sur-mer
il était de vos quinze ans vous avez aux
usa et vous dites est là c'est
intéressant par rapport à ce que dit
payant non je ne crois pas du tout à
l'intégration
je préfère le système des communautés à
l'américaine donc vous pensez que
l'intégration républicaine à la
française c'est un modèle obsolète
je pense que c'est hypocrite ouais on
est mieux ce soir avec les gens qui nous
ressemblent ces passants être sectaire
mais ouais aux états unis et voilà quoi
donc on laisse trop d'américains
retrouvons sans ils sont ensemble à
manhattan par exemple a pas de problème
le soir ils se retrouvent chez eux ils
n'ont pas de pension ils sont dorés à
noter avec les gens qui ne regardent pas
de
autant bas un chacun chez soi
moi je préfère en tout cas un modèle où
on peut avoir des gens qui sont divers
et qui vivent ensemble plutôt que d'être
chacun dans son coin et je pense quand
même que ce modèle est un modèle qui
amène entre ces communautés à des
violences qui sont extrêmement profonde
et avec des communautés qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus en difficulté que
l'autre ça me semble pas un modèle très
souhaitable je pense qu'on avait réussi
à faire ensemble c'est difficile à faire
alors qu'on dise moi je préfère l'être
avec celle qui sont comme moi etc
on le comprend tous parce qu'on a tous
un peu ça mais de là à dire sans les
autres c'est difficile mais j'ai fait
une interview l'année dernière à la
prison fleurs energy sse et je leur
expliquais que est donc vain je leur
posais la question à savoir la d'être en
prison maintenant ici est ce que ça leur
permettait à eux d'avoir une remise en
question sur eux-mêmes et éventuellement
d'évoluer devoirs et les gammes disait
non parce qu'en fait on nous replonge
comme ils émettent par secte par secteur
c'est ça notre communauté en faisant ce
délai légal les brouillards of man 2
quand les gens me créhange dedans comme
un peu on ne replonge dedans si haut si
effectivement on était un petit peu là
là là là là on serait en fait on se
retrouve tous les mêmes qui étaient dans
les cités à faire des conneries se
retrouvent pareils sont donc ils peuvent
pas évoluer il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas un vrai travail un suivi pour
essayer justement de leur ouvrir
d'autres horizons pas pour pour pour
vous l'avenir et du tout communautarisme
en fait vous pensez que l'intégration
républicaine c'est un modèle dépassé
moi je pense en tout cas ici cinq ans
pour apprendre ouais ça marche pas parce
que vous dites vous par exemple quand il
fallait me réinscrire au collège
ma mère me disait tu ne montres pas
comme ça me merlet
blanc ça passe mieux ouais par exemple
vous dites en france même avec une belle
voiture tu ne fais contre les deux fois
par jour il ya toujours vous dites ce
plafond qu'on n'arrive pas à percer il
ya quel que soient les moyens dont on
dispose
quand on est noir on sera toujours un
sous citoyen c'est ce que vous dites en
fait moi je pense avec moi avoir à
penser que c'est sans espoir
j'ai pas trop d'espoir ce niveau là tu
vois c'est quand même s'ils disent ah
enfin moi ce que j'entends c'est qu'en
même temps il ya une forme de regret
parce que je vois pas pourquoi il serait
pas un citoyen comme les autres donc ça
condamne pas le modèle républicain sa
ville
ils marchent mal les indices évidents
qui marche mal mais nous qui marchent
pas à mon avis ça marche mieux quand
même que là où il ya pas mais et il a
des ratés terrible il a des ratés depuis
20 ans considérable et d'ailleurs on
voit les brisures moi ça me donne plutôt
le sentiment qu'il faudrait que ça
marche mieux
vous me dire ce modèle là je pense que
ça le labour les trois là il ya des gens
qui croient plus du tout à jegun
s'inquiétant vous dites je raconte la
dure réalité le mal de vivre
si on mettait mes textes en images ce
serait sûrement interdit aux moins de 16
ans que des textes extrêmement violent
il ya même dans votre cv raymond viol
texte dans votre cd qui est bâtiment
c'est quand même pas reproduit sur le
livre est tellement il est violent c'est
pour éviter les ennuis avec la justice
on dérange protex un mais bien mais bon
pour moi c'est énorme
l'album qu'elle deuxième album solo vous
faites booba s'appelle panthéon c'est
chez barclays vous pensez que cette
musique ce genre de texte devrait avoir
sa place au panthéon forcément se blesse
un symbole oui mr dire qu'on essaye de
faire de grandes choses quoi ouais vos
chansons racontent les gonzesses les
flingues les flics les bandes des cités
la cam est la plus sympa tout c'est
numéro 10 c'est la plus optimiste
il n'est pas numéro 10 à paris et rabat
l'unss du ciel la rose offert au poste
les foetus
numérotée comme arrêter ma part
hertz numéro un serbe a pris d'envié ou
dans l'art et plus d'air dans son père
pourtant les deux
mais orlando exige le clip
pourquoi des bois numéro 6 marc parent
trap alain du siècle là où son père en
brossant les victimes teulé numéro des
100 mains c'est bon ça c'est de lombers
me faisait résonner serbe imprimons rim
sur leurs airbus dauzère la hausse vers
les véhicules et des numéros des homards
theora j'ai créé produit et je suis
chauffeur livreur beaucoup de larmes ont
entièrement entouré de six frères negro
ne plaisante pas avec le bipe au qg rose
et les héros trop enlevée à trois points
on
évitez chez bar chez l'adversaire
[Applaudissements]
je pense que non
oui ça c'est le plus sympa plus positif
alors on vous compare à jeûner en vous
compare à céline et c'est vrai que
finalement on pourrait dire que je n'ai
céline c'était des rappeurs sans musique
personnellement moi je les ai pas lu je
connais pas donner ce qu'ils font c'est
que c'est des grands écrivains m
on sait pas plus on est passé dit ne
rougit pas cette chanson alors de mettre
le 25 août à bercy avec fish 600 voix la
première partie c'est bien vous sourirez
jamais qu'est ce qui pourrait vous faire
plaisir car deux membres entre de tes
questions à la con
[Musique]
océans